he's great quarterback I certainly put
him up there against anybody but you
know I don't really feel like it's my
job you know rape people he's a great
player has been a great player for the
New England Patriots certainly his
record is unmatched plays my quarterback
that's Bill Belichick talking about Tom
Brady says it's not his job to rape
people but you know what he rated LT
Lawrence Taylor and said he's the best
he ever coached and as we try to
psychoanalyze Bill Belichick here this
morning on POF July first let me say
hello we're here at radio row in Atlanta
site of Super Bowl fill of three how you
doing Sims back again glad to see you
you're like back again like I've look
I'm here almost every day you ever know
when you're not going to show up you
strike me as the kind of guy who
eventually is just not gonna show up and
have no excuse for it other than sorry
I didn't wake up I would never do that
I've never been late for a football
meeting anything you know I might have
cut it close a few times that I'll
always be here
you've never cut it close either you're
always well there was one day where one
day you got a little worried I remember
I'm so used to going up to my studio at
my house and seeing my monitor and
seeing you applying your makeup and then
as soon as you notice me giving me the
double-barreled mental Fingal there's no
day you weren't there and I thought boy
where is Chris but that's one time in
two years so that's good but we are here
for the remainder of the week we will
have Dan Marino coming up Pat McAfee
Josh Jacobs the Alabama running back but
this Bill Belichick quote struck me as
interesting because we spent Chris so
much time trying to figure out when Tom
Brady is going to choose to stop playing
football yeah we can't lose sight of the
fact that he may not be immune to the
Bill Belichick principle of getting rid
of a guy one year too early right
instead of one year too late with all
these young quarterbacks popping up
every year
deshaun Watson Patrick mahomes Baker
Mayfield here comes Kyle Emery
here comes Dwayne Haskins here comes
this guy at some point there's gonna be
an urgency in that organization and it
may even go higher than Bill Belichick
it may infiltrate ownership where they
say boy we love Tom like a son yeah but
it's time to get a new son right as your
dog gets older yeah bring in the new
dog hole dog dies or nay you don't want
the kids to get upset so I gotta go find
this new dog at some point and you
wonder at what point they're gonna go
get their new dog well they brought it
and you chose not the best similar we're
gonna but we're gonna ride with ace
since you went with it but I mean they
brought in a new dog and Jimmy Garoppolo
okay and you know Tom just still said no
I'm gonna continue to play at this level
that you see here I'm not gonna fall off
and they said okay new dog we gotta find
a new family for you and they sent aha
but but I think the big thing with
Belichick and Brady as far as ranking
him right okay Bella checks not gonna
rank Tom Brady at this point in his
career yeah and Bella checks career
because he's still coaching Tom Brady so
he's not gonna even get into that
you know discussion he wants Tom Brady
to still be the captain or the commander
of his his his ship in the offense and
he doesn't want to get into oh yeah well
I think tom is the greatest ever in this
love affair before they play a big
football game he wants Tom to be
mentally sharp have that edge about him
I think all of that is there and to your
point about drafting that new dog or
quarterback I do think that we could see
that happen this year I think this could
be the year where they do it and have
him ready for you know two years three
years down the road to then take over
for a Tom Brady do you think that Tom
Brady here's what Belichick said or
didn't say and gets upset like why don't
why don't you praise me more what do I
have to do to get praised by a year do
you think he understands that bills not
going to do that because we have a game
coming up it wouldn't look good it
wouldn't look right it wouldn't be built
right if he praises me for being so
great four days before we're ready to to
take on the Rams in Super Bowl 53 yeah I
think I think Tom probably has had
moments where he's probably throughout
his career gone man I wish my my head
coach would give me a little bit more
respect right Fran yes that's right but
this sets wickersham and everything
about it and I'm sure that eats at Brady
at times but I'm sure Belichick knows
and eats at Brady too and he probably
likes it I always go back to when I was
there there was always the talk in the
building that that Belichick felt Wes
Welker played better when he was mad or
angry at the coaches and I Belichick
kind of you know you know
fueled that flame all the time
throughout the weeks to kind of get wes
welker to go and be ready to go so I'm
sure that's there but at the same time I
do think Tom Brady realizes that Bill
Belichick is not getting into the
rankings and gonna go you know well I'd
put you know I'd put Montana 1 and Brady
2 and Marino 3 and get into that he's
just not gonna do that to the at this
point and I think there will be a day
down the road where he will sit down I
think I like Bill Walsh he kind of did
the same thing he'll sit down with some
people in the media and start to wax
poetic ly about a Tom Brady and he'll
pop up Tom Brady at that point to
motivate whoever is quarterback is right
right yes you want to be like Tom hey
you want to sorry like Tom was here at
5:30 Tom didn't leave till 11 o'clock at
night you know what I mean he will he's
gonna push those buttons on that guy but
the other thing is to you like do you
think bill has the authority now bill
has the authority over a lot but this
bill have the authority in New England
to go you know I think it's time to move
him on like one year before it's time
how you talked about like the lawyer
Milloy or whoever it was where he's
always gotten rid of that guy I don't
think he has the authority over the
Kraft family when it comes to Tom Brady
I think Tom Brady literally can call his
shot when he wants to stop playing well
that was part of the Seth Wickersham
story from last year that Bill Belichick
didn't want to trade Jimmy Garoppolo and
part of that story was that Brady was
threatened by Garoppolo and wanted
Garoppolo out so they moved Garoppolo
and Bill only took a second round pick
and specifically hand-picked the 49ers
thinking that Garoppolo would thrive
with Kyle Shanahan in San Francisco and
it would make bill look good for finding
Jimmy Garoppolo right but Garoppolo is
gone and Brady's still there and
remember when John Lynch the jam in the
49ers first called Bill Belichick about
a quarterback he said hey will you treat
me Tom Brady and maybe Bill Belichick
would have been inclined to consider it
but I don't think the crafts at that
point we're ready to go but
circumstances have changed since then
yes Patrick mahomes I think is one of
the big reasons circumstances have
changed her I've seen all these great
young quarterbacks and I'm telling you
at some point the crafts are going to
come to the conclusion that our
greatness has been fueled by having a
guy that we brought in young who
developed into a great quarterback
let's get this next guy in here let's
let him develop and let's get
him to the point where he's ready to
nudge out Tom Brady the way that Brady
was ready to nudge out through Bloods
okay you know before Drew Bledsoe gets
blown up on the sidelines by Moe Lewis
in 2001 Tom Brady is thinking I'm gonna
take over for this guy Bill Belichick at
some levels thinking Tom Brady's gonna
take over for this guy at some point and
that point came sooner than later so I
think there's gonna be there's gonna be
that mindset at some level of the
organization that there has to be they
can't ride this out for the next five
years no they come in five years that
would be ridiculous
one year okay I'm definitely two years I
think that's where I look at it I say
Tom Brady goes two more years depending
how next year goes I mean I do think
that hey he still can throw the ball
we've seen that they have shown the
ability to protect them that's gonna
increase those chances to get into
another a second year after this Super
Bowl but I still think that at some
point Brady's gonna have to just check
himself a little bit and go you know
what okay it is time there is a
quarterback coming up the ranks behind
me and we need to I need to check my ego
at the door and move on and go on to the
next phase of my life and the thinking
is that Tom Brady if he's ever nudged
out of New England will choose to play
somewhere else
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports